Hey there, thrill-seekers!
Are you ready to get crazy?
Are you ready to get extreme?
Are you ready to taste the real hardcore?
We here at SCP Explained know that you love
a little excitement in your life.
You’re the kind of stone-cold, solid gold
bad dude whose idea of a relaxing afternoon
is a staring contest with SCP-173 - and you’re
so tough, you’re gonna make that Peanut
blink first!
You’re the kind of person who’d punch
SCP-682, and make him apologize for grazing
your fist.
You wouldn’t even back down from the Scarlet
King himself, making this Monarch of Ultimate
Despair say, “That’s pretty cool, man.
Respect.”
But if you want a genuine thrill ride, something
that’ll really put hair on your chest, you
need to get your butt on a truly hardcore
rollercoaster.
What, too chicken?
Afraid of a little motion sickness or something?
Or maybe you’ve been freaked out by some
of the so-called “horrifying accidents”
that happened on rollercoasters - like the
1972 Big Dipper Disaster,
or the 1986 Fantasyland Mindbender Catastrophe?
Get real.
When has a little death scared anyone at the
SCP Foundation?
And besides, nothing is more awesome than
an extreme rollercoaster, and believe us,
any other rollercoaster will feel like kiddie
stuff compared to the absolute beast we’re
gonna tell you about today.
If you’re a rollercoaster novice, maybe
you should try something like the Takabisha,
over in the Fuji-Q Highland theme park in
Japan.
This baby boasts a 121-degree drop, famous
for making people fall out of their seats.
Or maybe you want to try something like Yukon
Striker over in Canada.
This widowmaker of a coaster has floorless
seats, a 360-degree flip, four inversions,
and a 75-meter drop.
That’s a little too tame for your taste?
If you’re feeling really brave, you can
hop on the Kingda Ka, over in the New Jersey
Six Flags theme park.
You’ll get a super-fast ninety-degree climb,
followed by a bone-stripping 139-meter drop,
a 129-foot camel hump, and a 270-degree spiral.
That’ll give you a healthy dose of Vitamin
G-Force!
Why are we telling you about all this?
Because compared to SCP-2183, all those coasters
are like riding a tricycle with stabilizers
in your mom’s backyard.
There is no coaster more powerful, more thrilling,
and more adrenaline-pumping than SCP-2183.
Let’s take a look at some of the specs.
You can find this bad boy in an undisclosed
location somewhere in Idaho.
This ride is so hardcore, the killjoys over
at the SCP Foundation don’t want you to
ride it.
But if the lame-o’s over at the Foundation
had their way, nobody would be having any
fun!
Look at how they put the kibosh on the Carnival
of Horrors, or as they call it, “SCP-823.”
Anyone who wants to go on one of those rides
will just meet the business end of a Foundation
sniper rifle.
And think about all the kids who’ve been
deprived of the awesome childhood experience
of Cragglewood Park, aka SCP-2571, because
the Foundation party poopers decided to rain
on everybody’s parade.
It’s safe to say that if the Foundation
wants to keep you away from it, you’re gonna
have a dope time with it, and the SCP-2183
rollercoaster is no exception.
They have the whole park blocked off and patrolled
by at least four security guards at any given
time.
People who see this beast in action get given
Class F Amnestics, and they’ve spared no
expense in suppressing anything about this
coaster to end all coasters in the media.
But trust us, getting a ride on this thing
is totally more than worth getting on the
SCP Foundation’s bad side.
That’s right.
This killer coaster has a max height of 37.2
meters and a max speed of almost ninety kilometers
per hour.
You can’t drive that fast anywhere but the
Autobahn over in Germany!
Sure, it may technically be “unfinished”,
but this bad boy still has a physical track
length of 798.8 meters.
You’re probably wondering why we said “physical”
there, right?
That’s because, when it comes to SCP-2183,
the real ride starts when the track comes
to an end, baby!
When the ride starts a-rollin’, it blasts
down the normal tracks like a bullet, but
when the track ends and the carts fire off,
they don’t fall.
No way.
The carts keep speeding, mid-air, continuing
on the intended track from the rollercoaster’s
initial badass blueprints.
But that doesn’t mean this ride does everything
by the book; SCP-2183 is a ride that knows
how to party.
There’s never any predicting the exact ride
length, cause every time the carts fire off
the uncompleted section of track, they take
a totally different path back to the start.
That makes SCP-2183 officially the most unpredictable
rollercoaster in the entire world!
The shortest recorded length of the non-physical
section of the track is 1,080 meters, that’s
almost double the length of the physical track.
And the maximum length of the non-physical
portion of the track has been 5,460 meters,
which is over twice the length of the Nagashima
Spa Land’s Steel Dragon 2000, the longest
rollercoaster in the world.
But we know what you adrenaline junkies are
thinking: It ain’t just the length that
gets a major buff, it’s also the height
and speed.
Top recorded heights on the mid-air tracks
have been up to 100 meters, making it the
fifth tallest rollercoaster in the world.
And speeds have reached a face-melting 180
kilometers an hour, making it the fourth-fastest
rollercoaster in the world.
But maybe, like Shania Twain, that don’t
impress you much.
We get it, you’re probably thinking, “Fifth
tallest?
Fourth fastest?
I thought you said this coaster was truly
hardcore, SCP Explained!”
But like a good coaster, that’s just because
we haven’t hit you with the big twist yet.
That twist being: Everything we just told
you only applies to when the carts are empty.
When someone is actually on this absolute
monster of a rollercoaster, it starts to do
things you wouldn’t believe.
For you to really understand just how off
the rails this crazy train can go, we’ve
gotta tell you about D-93730, also known as
The Rider.
When the Rider woke up that morning, neither
he nor the Foundation researchers handling
him knew he was going to become a legend.
As far as D-Classes go, this guy was actually
pretty lucky - seeing that he’d been convicted
of one of the less severe crimes that constitute
D-Class duty, he was actually part of a release
program, allowing him to eventually exit the
Foundation alive and return to normal life
after he’d been involved in a certain number
of studies.
It seemed like a pretty fair trade.
However, this was a real “pearls before
swine” situation.
Any true Coaster Head would relish the opportunity
to take a joyride on SCP-2183; it’d be the
greatest honor of their lives.
But for The Rider, all it was was a source
of sweaty palms and an increased heart rate.
Talk about weaksauce, am I right?
He had no idea he was in for the ride of his
life, in what would be both the first and
last human test of SCP-2183.
They sat him down on one of the carts, strapped
and buckled him in with the safety bar, and
got that baby rolling.
When the ride began, the carts took the normal
path down the physical portion of the track,
but as expected, things got crazy when the
carts hit the anomalous portion.
Though nobody expected just how crazy this
ride would get, least of all our lucky little
Rider himself.
If he could still talk, I’m sure he would
have changed his tune by now.
The Rider’s cart detached from the rest
during the mid-air portion and took a sharp
right, going off on its own adventure around
the rest of the abandoned park.
Everybody knew this was going to be something
special, cause even the Foundation squares
had never seen a cart act like this before.
It looped around the whole place several times,
before whizzing through the park like a cruise
missile, weaving between rides, stalls, and
concession stands with ease.
It was traveling “blink and you’ll miss
it” fast.
This thing wasn’t just white-knuckle intense,
it was broken-knuckle intense.
The rest of the carts returned to the starting
point again and came to a stop, but the Rider
wasn’t getting off that easy.
There’s a reason we call SCP-2183 the most
intense rollercoaster in this crazy world
of ours.
The cart containing the Rider went AWOL, heading
north out of the park at high speeds, putting
it on a disastrous collision course with a
nearby town.
Well, disastrous if you work for the SCP Foundation.
Totally awesome for the rest of us.
The thing about a ride on SCP-2183 is that
you really get your money’s worth.
When people nickname this thing, “The Ride
Never Ends”, they don’t do that just for
fun.
This ride literally never ends.
Over the first few weeks of the Rider’s
ride, the Foundation just tried to suppress
news of sightings from spreading.
Multiple people around the nearest Idaho towns
reported seeing a flying rollercoaster cart
zipping around in the sky.
Thankfully for the killjoys of the world,
that kind of thing is easily written off as
a trick of the mind.
But that didn’t stop the Rider’s epic
thrill-ride from tearing it up all across
Idaho.
Over the next few months, this party train
really hit the road - metaphorically speaking,
of course, this cart consistently remained
120-150 meters above the ground and kept traveling
at consistent speeds of over 200 kilometers
an hour.
That makes it roughly tied for the second-fastest
rollercoaster in the world!
The people lucky enough to spot this bad boy
in action reported that they heard a panicked,
terrified screaming coming from inside the
cart as it passed.
That’s how you know that the Rider was having
a helluva time in there!
Real shame that anyone who spotted it got
a big ol’ dose of Class-A amnestics from
the killjoy brigade.
Speaking of those squares, the SCP Foundation
tried multiple times to stop the ride and
“save” the Rider from this awesome experience.
They sent in helicopters and lowered ladders
down to him, but the Rider, perhaps finally
appreciating what a gift he was given here,
kept his arms fastened to his sides, his face
forced into a permanent grimace.
Nobody knew how he could still be alive, despite
having no food or water in all this time.
We can only guess it’s because SCP-2183
is just that awesome.
Any time these Foundation dweebs tried to
get near the cart, it immediately undertook
evasive maneuvers and got the hell out of
there.
Nobody could bring this ultimate ride to an
end!
In the end, the SCP Foundation proved they
could take being anti-fun to straight-up military
proportions.
They approved firing a missile at this piece
of coaster dream-tech, hoping to finally bring
its awesomeness to an end.
After making a valiant effort to avoid them,
the missile eventually struck the cart.
They thought the Rider inside was dead, but
the cart kept flying for another four years
before finally crashing 34 kilometers from
the rest of the ride, relatively unscathed,
probably after crashing into one of those
beefy Idaho pigeons.
And as the Foundation would soon find out,
The Rider was still around too, he just wasn’t
in the cart anymore.
Nope, he was suspended in the air in a seated
position 124 meters above the crashed carts.
We call him the Rider cause he’s still riding
to this very day, and if anyone comes within
a 50-meter radius of him in any direction,
he’ll just fly away until he’s alone again.
We don’t know about you, but we think the
Rider’s whole permanent flying situation
isn’t a horrific purgatory of eternal torment
if he is alive under his comatose state - It’s
actually the ultimate ride.
And really, what more could you want out of
life, right?
Sometimes, people working on the site see
him sitting in the cars, often only for split
seconds.
He’s one with the coaster now.
Total Nirvana.
Like we said before, kids: The Ride Never
Ends.
Now go check out “A Sea Snail's Fantasy
SCP-1867 - A Gentleman” and “SCP-5094
- Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse” for more
interesting safe-class SCPs!